hello everyone this game was played in
2001 it was the first round of the
United States Open and Hikaru Nakamura
who was 14 years old at the time so he
didn't have his Grandmaster title yet
he's playing against John W Lloyd and
the mr. Lloyd hello rating of around
1900 so it was a quite quite a
difference in strength but it's a it's
amazing how this game shows how easy it
is to win when you when you play chess
really well and well Nakamura really
sure really makes just look simple in
this game so let's see this game
tomorrow is white and mr. white is black
we have E 4 and D 5 the Scandinavian
defense and the computer goes for Knight
to c3 and whiting like to push d4 so he
does he pushes v4 we have Knights ii ii
ii ii ii v defending the d4 pawn and
nakamura plays Knight to g3 Knight to f6
and now Knight to f3 attacking that he v
pawn Lloyd defense would Bishop to d6
and we have Bishop to c4
we had castles castles and now Bishop to
g4 and okay now come on replace h3 he
wants to see what what blacks plans are
with the bishop so capturing the
capturing tonight isn't really doing
anything for blacks so he plays a Bishop
to h5 and this allows nakamora a simple
tactic to place a nice captures on h5
Knight captures on h5 and here he plays
Knight captures on d4 so winning a pawn
here as this opens up for the attack
from the Queen and d12 this night on h5
and well black doesn't want to give up
the pawn for free so at least he plays
Knight to g3 you know doubling nakamora
spawns
nakamura place f2 captures ng 3 and we
have a capture son d4 and now d3 and ok
we can see that knock morris queen is
ready to jump to h5 g4 wherever is
necessary and also he's attacking this
f7 Square already with his rook and the
bishop on c4 so mr. Lloyd captured this
pawn on g3 so Bishop captures and g3
recovering the pawn and we have rook
captures on f7 by nakamura and
okay the idea is behind this move is
that this bishop is now in g3 so after
the exchange on f7 McNamara will have
Queen to f3 check and picking up the
bishop and g3 so rookie actors on f7
Bishop captures on f7 and I'm not
capturing the bishop mr. Lloyd doesn't
wanna lock into f3 check he plays the
king to h8 and here we have Queen TG for
developing the queen and also attacking
the bishop on g3 Bishop to e5 and now
Bishop to g5 would an attack on the
Queen and okay mr. Lloyd goes for Bishop
f6 and nakamora captures it Bishop
captures and s6 and well mr. white can't
really capture this Bishop with the
Queen for example the Queen captures an
f6 because he would run into Quinta CA
check and there are no more moves only
move as Queen to d8 and the Queen
captures and e8 is checkmate
so after Bishop captures on f6 mr. Lloyd
played G captures on f6 and here we have
rook to f1 again with a very simple
thread of rook captures on f6 the Queen
will not be able to capture back as
Queen the g8 will be checkmate so he
defends this Knight to d7 and here again
nakamura plays the strongest move he
plays Bishop to e6 now with a double
attack on this night on b7 and well then
I can't really go to f8 as this will
again be Queen to d8 checkmate and the
best move here was nice to e5 but here
after Knight to e5 Queen h4 with a
double attack on this pawn here it's not
clear how black would defend this so
after Bishop to e6 mr. Lloyd played
night to c5 and here Nakamura instantly
plays Bishop to f5 and this is with a
threat of Bishop captures on h7 and
after King captures rook the rook to f5
with a checkmate on h5 again a very
simple threat so Queen Cliff's Queen to
e7 mr. Lloyd defends this and Nakamura
nevertheless plays Bishop captures on h7
so now we have Queen captures on h7 and
rook to f5 and now attacking this knight
on e5 but also threatening rook to h5
and
winning the Queen so we have rocked the
g8 and now attacking a commerce Queen
and Queen to f3 again the thread is
capturing the night and also rook to h5
so you only move that really stops this
is rook to g5 which is played and
nakamura plays rook captures and g5f
capture 75 and the Queen to f8 check and
now we see why this night is really
misplaced here on c5 so pin to g8 and
now Queen captures on c5 and as you can
see mr. Lloyd has five points Nakamura
has seven points and while capturing
this pawn on a two doesn't really
achieve anything as Queen captures and
before would you check the fence b2 that
doesn't really win upon so mr. Lloyd
price Queen to g7 defending the pawn but
this loses the a 7 point we have b6 so
the Queen would be protecting c7 Queen
to 8 check King to h7 and now Queen to
c8 and a mr. Lloyd plays Queen to e5 and
now Queen to f5 check and in this
position mr. Lloyd resigned the game as
after Queen captures pawn captures well
there's really nothing for blade black
to play here after King to g7 King f2
after the king goes here simply g4 and
well Nakamura simply has too many pawns
so yeah after this after this Queen to
a5 check mr. Lloyd resigned and well
it's a very simple game about a
beautiful game so yeah I hope you all
had a great Sunday I hope you enjoyed
this game I would like to thank mr.
Harwood Navy for a contribution to my
channel thank you sir I appreciate it
and yeah that's it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank y'all for watching and I'll see
you soon